but tonight i want to speak from the
heart
as a patriot a christian
a citizen
and the parent of seven young kids in
this country
sometimes a data point hits our radar
screen that's bigger than the news of
the day a number that tells
a larger story a larger story about who
we are where we are
and what we're up against as a country
tonight that number is 31
remember it 31
today the harvard kennedy schools
institute of politics released their
bi-annual harvard youth poll they've
been doing the poll for 20 years asking
18 to 29 year olds so kids out of high
school out of college early in their
careers
asking them what they think about the
state of our country over a thousand
young americans were polled the margin
of error three percent
there were a number of fascinating
findings but one number stuck out to us
31 they were asked their views on
american exceptionalism is america an
exceptional nation
31 percent said america is the greatest
country in the world 50 percent
said other nations are greater greater
18 percent
out to launch
31 percent
three in ten young people in america
believe america is the greatest country
in the world
now i for one am not surprised by the
source as an alumni of the harvard
kennedy school of government it's an
elitist institution fully infected by
leftist group think it's the woke of the
woke trust me
they're not saddened by these numbers
they're globalists they don't want
america to be seen as the best
they're not saddened but we should be
now we checked the same poll in previous
years and other similar polls and the
closest comparison we could find today
was a 2013 gallup poll
that showed that 55
in the year of 2013 of americans that
same age were extremely proud to be an
american if you're extremely proud you
probably think america is an exceptional
place
so 55
in 2013 31
today in just a decade
and you don't have to be a historian to
know that if you went back a little bit
further
say to the 90s or the 80s that number
would be be much higher maybe 70 75 80
percent
here's why it all matters here's why 31
matters
if you go by the old adage the children
are the future
then plain as day
this poll shows that the future hates
america
or at least they think there's nothing
special about america it's just just one
of many countries
of course
i know because i get to travel this
great country and meet so many of you
with fox and friends that this is not
the universal view there is an echo of
goodness of patriotism of faith in the
american people of people who truly
believe and understand through history
and their own experience how special
this america and our experiment truly is
but if i had a dollar for every parent
who came up to me out on the road and
said my kid went to college as a
god-fearing patriot
and they came back
a bernie socialist who questions america
i'd be a rich man
uh and as we saw
over the last year i call it the uh two
years really the covid 1619 moment it's
when your kids were at home trapped in
zoom classes and you were over their
shoulder seeing the curriculum as the
1619 project and other elements of
critical race theory
and diversity equity inclusion came
across it was a moment where we saw what
they were really teaching
that it's not just colleges and
universities
it's elementary schools middle schools
and high schools
one of my mentors at princeton
university when i was an undergraduate
he's the constitutional law professor
there at princeton university his name
is robbie george
he had something to say recently about
what he's seen and how why he's seen it
coming for years listen to this
you know in the old days
uh there were
some liberal or progressive professors
who wanted to indoctrinate their kids
not all
but there were there were professors who
wanted to take the kid who might have
come from a farm family in iowa and is
now at yale or princeton
uh the kid was a boy scout the kid
was a church goer and uh and the liberal
professor would rub his hands together
and say okay i'm going to take this kid
brought up by
these these rubes and hicks out there
and i'm going to indoctrinate him in
liberal ideology
if such professors exist today
they must be very frustrated because
they lose their opportunity to
indoctrinate the kid because the kid
comes in pre-indoctrinated
now it's the other way around that's a
rough cut from a fox nation special i
have coming out next month it's called
the miseducation of america a five-part
series about the 100-year progressive
takeover of our country the conclusion
through that project we're surrounded
the leftists have nearly completely
captured our classrooms all of them
i went to public school in the 90s i got
a progressive education in a
conservative town
so did you in the way you were educated
so did all we all did we are all the
product of a progressive educational
system it's not immune in elite schools
it's not immune in private schools it's
not even immune in most religious
schools
see the takeover was not an accident of
the 1960s that's what i always thought
instead it was the product of an
intentional 100-year progressive
takeover an intentional targeting of
what made america different what made
america special what made america
exceptional today
31
you see america was founded on western
christian principles our founders the
product of the fusion the beauty the
brilliance of athens and rome and
jerusalem
they knew and understood the bible
inside and out they knew latin they
understood the classics they understood
human nature who we are as sinful
creatures
they built sinful creatures hell-bent on
power
and greed they built a system the first
in human history designed to restrain
government
and protect god-given rights for the
individual life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness if we can keep it
so while for decades patriots and
conservatives fought for good things
like free markets and defeating
communists and islamists the left
focused on culture and classrooms
they specifically targeted the way we
educate our young people by focusing on
removing the most important ingredients
they knew our judeo-christian faith and
tradition were the key to our human
freedoms our founders understood that
george washington talked about it so the
progressives knew they had to get rid of
it
they wrote it all down
men like john dewey and magazines like
the new republic education for the
youngest was their obsession in the
early 20th century the early
progressives they built an entire school
system predicated on the idea it's
called the gary plan my guess is you've
never heard of it i hadn't either before
this
they wanted to they knew they couldn't
remove god immediately because americans
were tethered to it so they had to
replace it with the new allegiance what
was it for the progressives early on
the flag they instituted a new pledge
called the bellamy salute francis
bellamy wrote it he was a socialist the
original pledge did not say under god
that was added by eisenhower in the 50s
during the cold war they wanted to
replace god with the flag later they
would discard that
the frankfurt school showed up in the
1940s a bunch of marxist professors with
a new theory called critical theory
their premise was to deconstruct western
civilization where did they land
columbia university the most influential
teachers college still in america today
now shortly thereafter the supreme court
did its work formally removing prayer in
school and bible reading
teachers unions the most powerful unions
in america today the nea and aft they
were not
initially formal unions before the 60s
they were soon captured by marxist as
well
the first president these education
unions ever endorsed jimmy carter and he
made them a promise that he would create
a federal department of education so the
nea created the department of education
and we never did get rid of it the most
popular textbook in america for the past
40 years
howard zins a people's history it is
literally american history if it was
written by the soviet union
it is the best it's been the best seller
as a textbook for 40 years if it's not a
textbook it is used in our textbooks so
the progressives removed god marxist
took over education marxists write our
history and then democrats are in bed
with them because they get elected by
the power of the unions
and now with the flag and patriotism
having served their purpose it's time
for them to go too
enter critical race theory which is the
follow-on to critical theory the 1619
project and full-blown
anti-americanism
see the point of liberal arts according
to our founders was to liberate minds
today it means to capture minds and tear
down what makes us great
we're definitely behind the curve
as andrew breitbart said politics is
downstream of culture as my pastor chris
durkin said a couple of months ago
culture is downstream of faith
we used to worship an almighty god now
we worship an almighty government and
you a false utopian promise no wonder we
are where we are there is a way to fight
back and not enough time to talk about
it tonight i'll leave that for the
special that's coming next month but it
starts with me and it starts with you
it's been heartening to watch parents
stand up at school boards and fight back
but as my mother did the same thing in
the 90s at our local school board did
things change
not really it's kind of like charging
fortified machine guns nests with nerf
guns it's not going to work we honor the
charge but it's not changing a system
that's totally fortified
it starts in our homes our churches in
our schools including new schools if you
have never heard of classical christian
education you should take a look at it
thirty one percent of young americans
believe america is exceptional they
don't know history they don't know the
world and it's scary
as abraham lincoln said the philosophy
of the school room in one generation
becomes the philosophy of government
in the next
can you keep a country if you're
teaching young people to hate that very
same country
we
are about to find out
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else